- What's up y'all?
I'm here with comedian
Joyelle Johnson, give it up!
So if you've ever
shopped at a flea market,
you've probably seen
those piles of old letters
and photographs for sale.
You may have wondered, like,
where do these come from?
What happened to their
owners? Why are they here?
Well my next guest has
those same questions.
She's had those and decided
to do something about it.
She's known as The Heirloom Hunter.
She collects family
heirlooms and returns them
to the next of kin, all free of charge.
Say hi to Chelsey everybody!
So meet Joyelle.
- Nice to meet you, gorgeous.
- [Chelsey] Her eyeliner is amazing.
- [Kelly] I know!
- We both got fingernails.
- Yes, that is true, our nails--
- I know, but the glitter
I've been watching.
I know all, both your finger,
I know mine are so basic.
Okay, let's move on.
So wait, this is so unique.
I mean, what's your process like?
So you buy one, like do
you buy specifically things
you think you have a chance
at finding? Obviously.
- So I always try and find
items with identifying marks.
Names, date, locations.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The more the merrier.
There is a myth that these items
just end up at the flea market
because people throw them
out, which is so not the case.
Most of these items end
up at the flea market
because of family drama.
So for example, someone
gets access to an estate
and then doesn't give the items
to the rest of the family.
But basically what I do is I just,
I put in all names and locations
into an online database
and I just see what pops up.
So sometimes a census record will pop up,
sometimes a public family tree
where I can message the owner
of that public family tree.
But it really just depends on each item.
But one of my favorite returns
was actually Valentine's day
cards from around World War II.
And what's special about these cards,
and what was emotional for me about them
were honestly, it was just the return.
I returned them to the granddaughter
of the couple who sent back
and forth Valentine's day cards
while the husband was in the Navy.
And the granddaughter said to me
when she received the cards, was,
it felt like you brought
my grandparents back
for those few moments that
I was reading the card.
- Oh my God, she's.
- Girl, I got lashes on.
- I'm sorry.
- Girl, I got.
- [Kelly] It's so sweet.
- But it was one of my
most special returns
and I was weeping, she was weeping,
it was just a lot of weeping.
Yeah.
- She is weeping.
Do you have anything in like your,
the only thing I have in
my family thing, I think,
for my mom is my grandmother,
and it's like vinyl records.
And I think my mom gave
them to me, obviously,
the musician in the family.
But do you have anything
in your family that you?
- I have this Swarovski ring
that I got for my 40th
birthday for myself.
So...
this will be a family heirloom.
- So this will be a family heirloom?
- Yes. I love it. That
is a family heirloom.
- It will not end up in a thrift store.
- So, we will be passing this on.
You are starting it.
- Yeah.
- So wait, so this is beautiful work
but it's gotta be pretty emotional, right?
- Yes.
- Have you ever showed
up and given something
to someone and then it didn't go well?
- Yes. So, but not in the
way that you would expect.
So I found love letters from the 1960s
and I returned them to a
woman who's still alive.
The would-be recipient.
And she had never received the letters.
So when I gave them to her,
it was her first time reading them.
And it was very traumatic for her
because that was someone
who she was dating
and she never received those.
She thought he just stopped
corresponding with her,
but he didn't.
- Oh no!
- She thought he ghosted?
- Yeah.
- Oh my goodness.
- So, it, yeah, yep.
- It's a first ghosting right there.
- Yes!
- And so it brings up that question, like,
could they have ended up together
if she did receive the
letters back in the 60s?
So that was painful for her,
it was painful for me,
but it wasn't painful.
She was so glad that I
did return those letters.
- Yeah.
- But it was more of, or give them to her
for the first time.
But--
- Because imagine the healing
that could come from that,
you know what I'm saying?
Like knowing that you weren't ghosted.
- Yeah.
- Right? And I think
that did cause, I mean,
listen, it provided closure.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- For her.
- [Kelly] Amen.
- And I mean, she's remarried
now and very happy, but--
- Wouldn't it be funny if she walked in,
and she was like I could
have ended up with him!
- Yeah. Wait.
I'm waiting for her to
just walk in right now.
- Yeah yeah.
- [Chelsey] Right?
- So, in some ways
you're following in
your father's footsteps.
Because I heard he's
a genealogist, was he?
- [Chelsey] Yes. That is correct.
- That's amazing.
- So my dad is a
genealogist and growing up,
so I'd see him help families
all around the world.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- For free, by the way.
And--
- Is that Downton Abbey?
- That is Downton Abbey.
Yep.
- [Joyelle] Your girl knows a castle.
- Yep.
I know Downton Abbey very well.
But I saw him help families
all around the world for free.
And I have to admit growing
up I did not find it cool.
Especially when I was a teenager.
- Yeah.
No, we never find cool stuff
cool when we're young, yeah.
- Of course.
And I do think though it
did hurt my dad's feelings
in a way, but as I grew up
I started to become more
attached to genealogy.
I started enjoying it more.
- Yeah.
- It's really fantastic.
- So one of your most beloved
discoveries was letters.
They were letters written
by Holocaust survivor?
- Survivor. Yes they were. So--
- How intense was that, first
of all? Just reading it.
- I was, well, since starting this journey
I have to admit that
Holocaust documentation
has been my number one priority,
getting it off of the market.
Unfortunately, people do
sell Holocaust documentation
either underground or at
auction for very high prices.
But reading that letter
was very emotional for me,
especially that return.
The letter was basically to say,
it was the day that Ilse
left the camp and she,
the letter was to her sister in England
basically telling her that
everyone in her family had died.
Mom, dad, two sisters and her husband.
And so yes, but the
story behind this letter
and how I got it is
actually pretty interesting.
There's a Spender that I
always use in New York city.
Well, not anymore, we'll get to that.
But I frequently get
love letters from him.
And I remember in passing in October
he mentioned that he had
Holocaust documentation at home,
hundreds of documents
that he was gonna sell
for thousands of dollars. Disgusting.
But I knew I had to get
my hands on those items.
So I started this strategy
to get him, to persuade him
to show me the letters, to bring them in.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so I found the
translation of that letter
and the second that I
found the translation
and I knew what it was,
I knew I couldn't tell
him what it actually was
because if I did, he either
wouldn't have sold me the letter
or would've sold it to me
for thousands of dollars.
So I told a little fib and I just said,
the letter was about food stamps
and could I buy it to give to the family?
And so I did. I bought it, but.
- Sneaky!
- Sneaky, but, and to be honest,
I would do it again in a heartbeat.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was able to--
- You're trying to get it to the family.
- [Chelsey] Yes.
- Yeah.
- [Chelsey] And there's a moral
aspect that comes with it.
- I mean sneaky in a good way.
There's good sneaky.
- I would do it again in
a heartbeat if I could.
- Oh, well we actually have
Ilse's great niece Jill
dialed in right now.
So, hi Jill.
- Hi.
- So Jill,
what did you think when you
first heard from Chelsey?
- I was really blown away
and amazed by her kindness
and the fact that she would
spend her time and energies
reaching out to connect me with a letter
in the actual handwriting
of my favorite great aunt
who was really more like a
grandmother to me growing up
because she didn't have
any children of her own.
And she, herself in her youth,
they say she looked like the
actress, Marlene Dietrich.
She was blonde and blue eyed,
so she could pass as Aryan.
She actually was part of
an underground organization
in Berlin that was actually
protesting the fascists
early into the 1940s.
And then when she was captured
she was actually sent on a
transport train to Auschwitz,
which amazingly she jumped off.
One of the only people who
survived such transports
and went back to Berlin,
was hidden underground.
And this letter is
shortly after liberation.
She's writing to her
only surviving sister.
And as Chelsey said, she's telling them
for the first time that
their other two sisters,
their brother-in-law, their parents,
and Ilse's second husband Gerhardt
had all been murdered.
And it's just unbelievable
that this is the emotion
that she must have had
to put in this letter,
to send it.
And on the receiving end,
to be the one to find out
that your family is gone.
- Yeah, I don't get.
I, can you imagine like
unexpectedly just
receiving family letters?
Like anything like that?
- Oh, yeah.
Well, my great great grandfather
was a part of the slave narrative.
So we like, he sent, you
know, letters and stuff,
and they documented his
experience in slavery. So.
- So you have actually?
- [Joyelle] Yeah.
- That's hard.
- Yeah. Absolutely.
- But also a reason to like, I guess,
be so thankful for that,
for the fact that like you
get this life right now,
you know what I'm saying?
Like we all get this life right now.
- Absolutely. Yes.
- Jill, what does it mean
to you and your family
to have these letters back?
And you know, it's in in her
words, it's in her handwriting.
That's pretty amazing.
- It's really wonderful.
And the letters themselves,
like the one that you showed,
the first line, it translated says
through the kindness of our liberators.
So that really epitomized my great aunt,
of what she was like, that
just, this sense of gratitude
she kept up after the war,
when the tables turned
and she was in the US,
she sent needed supplies and money
to the people who had hidden her
and helped them rebuild their
lives in postwar Germany.
And just to have this
memorial that I hope to frame
and put in my room in my home,
so that anybody who sees them
can see and ask me about it,
can learn Chelsey's story,
and learn that there are people
who do good in the world.
That Chelsey is someone who
takes their own energy and time
and money and efforts and talents
and reaches out and
connects people like me
with a piece of my family that's gone
is, I'm forever grateful
- And history is so
important. So important.
So we don't forget it.
- No. We can't forget. Never forget.
That's why people say never forget.
- I love that. Thank you so much, Chelsey.
Thank you so much, Jill, for sharing.